[Music]
afternoon everybody so I'm going to talk
to you a little bit more about some of
the components that you can find in more
detail in the report I'm going to try to
be quick here we have a lot to cover and
Tucker in a moment we'll cover one of
the impact categories of pathogen so I
want to leave them some time
the first thing usually we like to talk
about when we've been talking about this
is that manure irrigation is just a
component of a mature system right and
it's the land application component and
and one of the things that we try to
remind everybody that we talked to this
about is manure irrigation is a
selection of practice and it's going to
be compared to other manure application
practices so a lot of times we try to
keep that in mind in our discussion and
that this wasn't manure irrigation or
Nothing right typically all of these
fields that were talking about in what
continent has irrigation equipment if
they didn't get irrigated with manure
they get traditional or other types of
manure application applied to them so we
try to really frame this as you're
trying to compare this to other
technologies and see what the benefits
or drawbacks are um the other thing that
is important to notice to note is that
it's part of the system and one of the
things is manure irrigation you can't
really accomplish manure arrogation
without doing at least some minor
processing typically it requires some
solid removal you can accomplish that
with some complex systems processing
systems botanical systems or we've seen
a few people achieve it through multi
stage storages so there's a few options
and how you do that but the majority of
a manure irrigation system can't handle
solid at the content level that are that
is traditionally found as a treated or
even as it's diluted in manure storages
there are lots of things that a system
can control that you can control in a
system um oh there we go um so one of
the things we told people we're tried to
get them to understand there's a lot of
pieces
a lot of management to each system as we
discussed a lot of this stuff so I want
you to become a little familiar with
some of these things that not all
systems are the same and that there's a
lot of pieces that may impact the types
of things we're talking about like odor
or runoff or other things so one of the
things we try to remind people you can
control the rate of application you can
change the pressure and the nozzle type
right the nozzle types used for manure
are much larger on the traveling gun
that can handle maybe for maybe up to 5%
total solids on the manure irrigation
the center pivot system the types of
nozzles sometimes are called trash
nozzles or other things that are used
for manure are very different than what
you use for water irrigation right and
they produce profits that are much
different than what you would see in
traditional application systems that
apply water or maybe apply some kind of
chemical right so it's the conditions
that might apply for those systems might
be very different than the ones that
apply here also there's an end gun on
the system so we talked a lot about that
you can turn that on or off and that
there are really computerized systems
that are out there that can help you
detect wind speed automatic shutoff
turning off certain components for
working over waterways etc so here's
just a few images this is what we have
drop-down nozzles right these were a
really big discussion point and that the
lower you could get your drop nozzles
closer to the crop would be beneficial
again in a lot of these Center pivots
you can get nozzles drop nozzles that go
all the way to the ground um in this
case you can see these are higher up
because they grew corn in this field and
later in the season they didn't want to
have to change out the position but it's
really important that you understand
that all of the systems are not the same
and that the impact from where you have
dropped nozzles your release height is
quite important so here's a picture of
one of the nozzles playing manure again
this is a specialized nozzle and the
pressures that we run under pivot
systems with when you are on are much
lower and we typically run them with
water
so in general the nozzles and the
pressures are designed to have larger
droplet sizes and in a moment I'll talk
about some impact categories and why
that's important next I think my
computer seems to want to move forward
here there we go um is that you can have
some control system right there really
advanced control system so this so that
you can shut off even like a pie slice
or you can shut off very small zones in
these very irate irrigation application
so we had a lot of discussions about oh
well I want I how am I supposed to I
need to operate through a waterway and
we were saying no there are technologies
to avoid things like operating through a
waterway and shutting off and trying to
protect certain resources when you're
using it - all right when we were
talking about the practice there are a
lot of things we centered our discussion
around which include when we apply
manure you with an irrigation system how
does that change or a droplet movement
how does that disperse when it disperses
when we're talking about pathogens we
have some microbial and activation from
the sunlight how this temperature how
this humidity affects that microbial
inactivation how a lot of times we got
to talking about setback distances how
far should I be from a house where well
or surface water is this practice have
advantages or is it this advantageous to
use in comparison to other practices in
terms of groundwater penetration we do
have some areas with like karst
fractured bedrock in Wisconsin and so it
was a big discussion of whether whether
we would see benefits or drawbacks from
this system compared to exhibition okay
so what we did it we kind of in the
report there's a lot more detail about
each of these if you want more but we
kind of broke down the impact factors
into five areas one was drips odor water
quality air
quality and pathogen so in the drift
area we heard a lot of people talking
about risk some talking about spraying
onto their house or spraying onto the
sidewalk and really this drift to us
means the aerial movement of liquid
outside the intended application area
and that's different from overspray
right we called overspray when you hit a
house or a sidewalk we define that as
overspray and we always agree that that
was not a practice that we would ever
support and that that should always be
avoided and you should be able to
control that with understanding your
irrigation system and using information
like wind information and other things
so drift is that movement typically
caused by wind so you're going to get a
little movement off of the intended area
and you need to be a little more careful
when you're applying near school right
so application a location becomes really
important in a lot of these we talked
about how there were not a lot of
regulations for other manure application
methods that drift was not important in
there but that we realize we really
needed to think about it more especially
if we had higher relief pipe or irrigate
for manure irrigation particularly with
center pivots and the traveling guns so
what the things we determined if you
wanted to use min irrigation it was
important to maximize your droplet size
and ASAE has a standard so we're talking
about medium to coarse and again the
type of systems were using here
generally produce larger droplet sizes
so you would want to select equipment
that and pressures that achieve that
droplet size that's in the medium to
coarse or higher range you want to
minimize your release height and then
you have to you know we really
recommended that you needed to keep an
eye on wind speed automatic shutoff
things that when the wind gets too high
you can see in that top picture that was
on a really windy day compared to the
bottom picture on a not very when you
say you can see the difference in the
drift that you see so the conditions are
really important and then also using
barriers and other things are really
important in order to minimize that
one of the thing one of the biggest
concerns without about manure irrigation
was odor and there really is odor is
going to be a bigger concern with manure
irrigation than almost any other manure
application method so the perception and
variable there are so it's a greatest
citizen concern um was first some of the
odors produced they had a lot of concern
for like being outside having repeated
applications that the odor was really
impacting their life so generally always
greater there are ways to mitigate
though in this case higher winds greater
than five miles an hour increases
dispersion so again now you're trying to
fail in the odor versus the drift and
kind of operating we recommended in this
five to ten mile an hour range you
wanted to be filled barrett barriers you
want to think about where are people you
know there are some cases in our state
where there were folks who had a
irrigation system that was nowhere near
anybody else they owned all the
surrounding fields and so drift and odor
were not really that big of a deal
there's other who are trying to operate
irrigation systems where their
boundaries were with that had houses
near them and if you're looking to put
an irrigation system in and you already
have it in those selection of those
fields is really a mistake and also we
talked about how manure processing could
really reduce some of the odors like
using a digest for a number of the
facilities that had irrigation has
digesters
again you can mitigate some of these
odors but comparatively to other
practices the newer irrigation order
will be greater water quality we talked
a little bit about this really we
started to think about that so long as
you would avoid application rates that
resulted in runoff that we may actually
with multiple applications be able to
see some of the impacts of leaching and
that we would have less penetration into
the into the soil surface and downward
with multiple applications instead of
one application in the fall or spring as
we do with traditional applications so
we saw this as a benefit
some ways but there really isn't any
direct information on manure we were
taking information and applying it from
other research and again we really
targeted that you can't use the
irrigation system through a waterway
right you have to use those more
controlled system to avoid that kind of
situation air quality we talked about
particulate matter greenhouse gas
emissions hazard hazardous air
pollutants we use OSHA occupational
standards and Wisconsin ambient air
standards to kind of look at where we
were falling when we use manure
irrigation now there's not a lot of data
from manure irrigation systems
particular particulate matter not very
much on greenhouse gas emission for that
particular land application but we just
talked about the mechanisms that may
increase or decrease in the report these
particular components obviously in a lot
of cases this type of application system
would increase some of these hazardous
air pollutants particularly hydrogen
sulfide people had some concerns about
we did have this state folks that the
public health had measured a number of
times around these systems and never
have really had a hydrogen sulfide
reading on that that they could document
as being close to anything near the
ocean occupational um again there are
similar mitigation techniques to the
other odor as using edge of field
barriers keeping larger droplets and
having a low reach in these height
there's one more impact category with
his pathogens and conkers going to talk
about that in a moment so I'm going to
leave that to him to cover um but I do
want to talk about just two additional
things before I let him take over one is
that we really talked a lot about
application tiny right and that we are
really we heard from producers a lot
that they're really running into these
scenarios where they cannot they don't
have enough time in the spring and fall
to apply their manure right it's
particularly those who are not allowed
to apply during a frozen ground and so
put kind of this imaging up just to give
an idea for people when you have
rainstorm or you have precipitation or
melting events you're really limiting
and you're not allowed to apply in the
winter you really have tight window some
years when you can get when you are out
in the field and so what we found was
irrigation is that that really expands
your windows and can reduce not not only
can you do multiple applications which
can be more tailored to the timing of
the plant so you might get better
nutrient use efficiency that you also
can avoid some of the issues that happen
you know what people apply during times
they shouldn't be applying because
they're facing a tight window or other
similar things to that you know it
issues with tons of road traffic at the
same time so we did think that there are
some significant benefits to be noted
with applications and then we have a few
scenarios and if you look at the report
you can see some other information we
are really trying to lay out what does
it mean if you switch from a more
conventional application system using
maybe tankers on the road to trying a
field with a manure irrigation right so
we said well you know there's a lot of
scenario to think about here but for a
certain size farm you kind of map this
out and say they had a bunch of fields
and this farm had 250 tanker loads a
year right and maybe they did one or two
applications or here on each skills now
that if they switch to having some
manure irrigation maybe they're tanker
loads reduced by almost half so you see
if you live near there you might be less
traffic but then if you live close to
the fields with manure irrigation you
may have more instances of application
and I think one of the important things
we talked about was setting some rules
on how many times you know we really had
some discussions about 20 tons if I live
next door to a field is way too many or
is reasonable right so we took we
discussed a lot about what that
application number should be if there is
a maximum or not and also a little bit
about setbacks which can we'll get to
some of the consensus
[Music]